[Musique]
joyeux noël arrive aussi par un ton
cadeau c'est à dire serait un objet et
inoubliable peu de gens conscience qu'il
existe de par le monde des royaumes où
règne le désordre
oui
c'est toi qui détient la clé de leur
secret
souviens-toi clara on ne doit pas se
fier aux apparences
vous êtes dans les quatre royaumes
princesse clara à votre service majesté
je passe peut-être un peu trop de ton
premier
bienvenue dans notre monde la terre des
flocons de neige
la terre des fleurs la terre des
friandises et le quatrième au royaume
qui est la source de tous nos ennuis la
mairie ginger a déclaré la guerre ne
sais tu pas qu'il est dangereux de
s'aventurer ici j'espère que tu pourras
m face il faut sauver le royaume ce ne
sont que les lois de la physique
elles sont vraiment fiable ces lois oui
donc je sache prête
[Musique]
oh
elle rassemble toutes ses troupes tu es
la seule qui puisse l'arrêter
je vous attendais ma chère
l'heure est venue